having a wellness instructor as a
preventative measure for People's Health
that is economical to be able to do that
virtually for 300 people at a low cost
of roughly two three thousand pounds a
month that is very economical when you
say Mansion for millions that was rented
for approximately a hundred thousand
pounds a year
that allowed us to constantly man that
house with over five to ten Executives
up in the Northeast there was no
misappropriation of fund because not a
single penny was spent on a private jet
hundred thousand went to a as you say a
mansion but it was a large house and if
you look at the cost of renting a hotel
room for that many people during that
period of time it was far more
economical to rent a house the fact that
it happened to have a pool that wasn't
working for 18 months by the way it has
nothing to do with it